[Müzik]
muskar Ben sadece muskar
ismi Mustafa Akan
2010 yılında Bursa'dan geldim
bambaşka bir serüvene atıldık
otomobil piyasasında
97-98'den beri olmaya çalıştığım
birisiyim
Bursa'da yaptığımız dönemlerde
otomobilcilik çok başka kullanlarda ve
çok başka algılardaydı şu anda bambaşka
platformlarda bambaşka şekilde yapmaya
çalışıyoruz
ama bir şey vardı kabıma sığmıyordum hep
hedefler başkaydı Hedef hep gökyüzü
Derdim o yüzden bu konuşmanda çatısını
Hedef gökyüzü yapmak istedim çok
kullandığım bir kelime her yerde
anlattığım bir konu
Çünkü ticaretlerin şekilleri aslında
birbirine çok benzer
sadece
yaptığınız ticari organizasyonların ismi
cismi değişebiliyor Bu araba olabiliyor
ev olabiliyor Mobilya olabiliyor değişik
standartlarda uygulanabiliyor ama
bizce ticaretin sınırları belli
çerçevelerde birbirine çok paralel Hele
ki günümüz türkiye'sinde
Bizde o dönemler kafamıza sığmıyorduk
otomobilciliği nasıl geliştiririz nasıl
değiştiririz neler yapabiliriz nasıl
artı bir katarız artı bir katmak çok
önemli yaptığınız işe katma değer katmak
çok önemli
2010 yıllarına kadar Bursa'da hem
akademik kariyerimize hem ticari ahlak
ve değerlerimizi geliştirerek belli bir
noktaya gelmeye çalıştık ama artık
dağımıza sığmıyorduk bir şey yapmam
gerekiyordu biliyordum Çok zorlu bir
süreç
ama işimize çok tutkuluyduk bu tutku
bizi bambaşka bir hayata bambaşka bir
serüvene ilerletti
bir karar aldım
Bursa'da kalmak çok kolaydı oto
galericiler içerisinde kalmak çok
kolaydı Çünkü hazır bir iş hazır bir
düzen hazır bir para
ve mesleği en iyi öğrendiğim kişi hala
onun bilgileriyle tecrübeleriyle
uyguladığım kişi Babam her şey çok
kolaydı oradaki işi kurmak işi
geliştirmek işi geliştirmek Aslında
birçok kişiye göre çok daha anlamlı ve
çok daha kolay gelebilir de
Ama şunu düşündüm orası hazır bir dağdı
annemin lafı geldi aklıma hazıra dağ
dayanmaz
düşündüm
bu dağların
kendi içimde nasıl geliştirebilirim
nasıl değiştirebilirim bir bilgi daha 2
tecrübe Dağı 3 hazır bir sermaye daha
Kendi işimde
hazırla daha dayanmaz diyerek kendi
dağımı yaratmak istedim
kendi dağılması sığınmak istedim
kendi dağımın arkasından hedeflerimi
belirleyip hedeflerimi yükselmek istedim
Çünkü
biliyordum ki mesleğime olan inancım tam
mesleğimle alakalı herhangi bir hedefi
koyarsam hangi hedefi koyarsam koyayım
ben bunu başarabileceğime İnanıyordum
Çünkü otomobil tutkunu bir kişiyim
otomobillerle yatıp Kalkan bir kişiyim
7/24 otomobillerle ilgili olan bir
kişiyim Dolayısıyla bu hazırların yani
hazır diye adlandırdım skalaların
kendime yetemeyeceğini düşünüp kendi
dağınımı yaratıp kendi devamını arkasına
sığınmaya çalıştım ve başlıca hedefler
koydum bu hedefler doğrultusunda Kolay
bir yol değildi zor bir yol Tabii ki
ama mesleğimize olan inancımızdan dolayı
İstanbul'a gelmeye karar verdim
ve
komisyonculukla bir şekilde
otomobilcilik çatısı altında
ticaretlerimize başladık hep küçük küçük
hedefler koydum kendime küçük hedefler
oldukça hedefler büyümeye başladı küçük
hedeflerin en arkada anında bile bir
gökyüzü vardı çünkü
hep şunu isterim Biz ölene kadar
çalışmalıyız
ki hedeflerimizi koyduğumuz
hedeflerimizi hiçbir zaman ulaşılabilir
doğrultuda kendimize hissettirmemeye
çalışmak için Dolayısıyla
Bu anlamda İstanbul'da başladığımız
dönemlerde
küçük küçük hedeflerle başlayıp çok
başka hedeflere yöneldik
ve kendi dağımızı yaratmaya çalıştık
kendimize bir iş yeri kurduk muskar
Mustafa'nın arabaları diye
her gün bir hedefimiz var Her gün bir
katman değer katmaya çalışıyoruz
Eskiden bizim yaptığımız sektörün algı
olarak hakikaten çok anlamlı ve çok
doğru algılarla yönetebildiğin
yönetilebildiğini düşünmediğim için bir
şeyleri değiştirmek istiyordum aslında
son 6-7 yıldır da sektörümüzle alakalı
birçok şeyi renklendirmek için çok ciddi
bir çaba çok ciddi bir gayret sarf
etmeye çalışıyorum
bunları yaparken Tabii kendi içinde de
belli başlı hedeflerim var çok çalışmak
çok uyumak çok uyumamak Yani az uyumak
ve çok çalışmak hakikaten bunları
yapmaya gayret içerisinde her gün bir
öncekinden daha fazla çalışma gayreti
içerisindeyim
Bir de Tutkun olduğunuz bir işte bunları
yapabiliyor olmak yapabilme yetisini
kazanmak insana çok daha fazla bilgi
beceri ve tecrübe sahibi yapıyor her gün
yeni bir şeyler öğreniyoruz
Ben de Bu sektöre karşı biraz daha
renkler renklendirdiğimi ve
renklendireceğimi de düşünüyorum o
yüzden Hedef hep gökyüzü olmalı Hedef
hep ulaşamayan ulaşmak istediğin ama
ulaşamayan bir tarafta olmalı ki
içinizdeki heyecan hiçbir zaman Bitmesin
Tabii ki birçok hedeflerimiz var gene
birçok planlarımız var Birçok
hayallerimiz var
Ben bir otomobilci olarak
bunları nasıl değiştiririm nasıl
geliştirebilirimin yönünde Aslında ben
bir otomobilciydim Fakat bu
otomobilciliği akademik kariyer ekledim
akademik kariyerden sonra akademik
kariyeri olan bir otomobilci olmaya
çalışıyorum bunları yaparken Daha Dürüst
daha anlamlı daha zekice ticaretlerin
daha değişken olduğu dijital dünyaya yön
veren bir otomobilciliği anlatmaya
çalışıyorum insanlara bunları Kendi
işlerimizde uygulamaya çalışıyorum
sistemi biraz daha değiştirmek adına bir
şeyler yapmaya çalışıyoruz hala
çalışıyoruz yani çok bizdeki bizim
sektörümüzdeki değişkenlik ivmesi diğer
sektörlere göre daha minimize bir
konumda
Dolayısıyla
ben ve Benim gibilerin Aslında bu
sektörde daha da
katma değer katıp daha da katkılı
olmaları gerekiyor tüketiciler için
nihai tüketiciler için
Daha sonrasında yurt dışına gittim yurt
dışında bir tane galeride çalıştım
oradaki galeride öğrendiğim bir modeli
şu anda kendi İş yerimizde uygulamaya
çalışıyoruz işte bir otomobillerin A101
Bedeli neyse onu yazmaya çalışıyoruz
oraya hiçbir Bedeli üzerinden
ticaretlerimizi ilerletmeye çalışıyoruz
tamamen Türk ve Avrupa Amerika
böyle otomobilciliği ile alakalı
harmanlanmış bir sistemi uygulamaya
çalışıyoruz
insanların psikolojisini bilmek Onlara
göre davranmak bence çok önemli
ticaretin herhangi bir dalı için
Biz de bu bağlamda Türk halkının
psikolojisini
hala
öğrenmeye çalışan kişilerden bir
tanesiyiz
bu hedeflerimizin hayallerimizin yanı
sıra
İş yerimizde uyguladığımız politikalarda
bunlarla da doğru orantılı gitmek
zorundayız
hedeflerimiz her gün artıyor Bence
artması da gerekiyor çünkü
hedeflerinizin artmadığı bir
konjektörde sizin kendi işinizle kendi
sosyal hayatınızda kendi ilişkilerinizle
hakikaten bir adım atma şansınız
kalamayabiliyor Dolayısıyla
hangi sektörde olursanız hangi işi
yaparsanız
Kendi işiniz veya bir başkasının işi
hakikaten kendinize de minik minik
hedefler koyup o hedefler doğrultusunda
ciddi anlamda yollar katedebilirsiniz
ama bence ben şöyle diyorum Bazı
yerlerde bana tepki veriyorlar başarmış
insan yoktur diyorum Çünkü başarma
hakikaten sonu yok nereye kadar
başaracağız yani onu aldık onu yaptık
bunu yaptık ama hani bir sonu yok sonu
olmadığı için de bu sizi çok daha aktif
ediyor
işinizle alakalı ilişkilerinizle alakalı
sosyal hayatınızla ilgili
durumlarda Dolayısıyla
Bence başarmanın sonu yok yani ben
başardım deyip bırakmak dünyanın en kötü
durumlarından biri olabilir benim
fikrimce
Dolayısıyla Biz de bunları göz önüne
alarak kendi İş yerimizde uyguladığımız
politikalarımız dışarıdaki uyguladığımız
politikalarımızla kesinlikle
hiçbir şekilde durmamayı çok daha fazla
neler yapabiliriz bu sektörü daha da
renklendirebilecek daha da
geliştirebilecek
daha da fazla anlam katabilecek artı bir
katabilecek hedefe hep gökyüzü
Tutabilecek neler yapabilirizi sürekli
araştırılması ve geliştirilmesi
içindeyiz
bugün burada olmaktan çok mutluyum Son
olarak şunu söylemek isterim önümde bir
oğlum var
Onun da adı Mustafa
ben bile bile koydum Hatta geçen gün
birisi şöyle bir şey söyledi abi dedi
herkes dedi iş yerine oğlunun adını
koyar sen iş yerinin adını oğluna koydun
hakikaten
bir şeyleri değiştirdiğime yüzde bir de
olsa inanan birisiyim
sektörümüzle alakalı
ve bir sonraki hayalim şu
babamın da bize bıraktığı bu iş bilgi
birikimi mirasına Ben de oğluma ne çeşit
ne şartlarda bırakırım bilemiyorum ama
şunu çok iyi biliyorum
ister muskarı devam ettirirsin ister
sıfırdan bir iş yapsın bizim gibi
ne yaparsa yapsın onun arkasında olup
onu destekleyeceğim bir babasını
olduğunu bilmesi Bana en büyük mutluluk
verecek hepinize teşekkür ediyorum
çok sağ ol